it's nobody's to answer that question
[Music]
even think right now it's so close my
girlfriends absolutely hi I'm Tom Ward
and welcome to in my personal space
my guest today is a star of a TV show
that for legal reasons we can't mention
by name introducing star of SH MAME of
SH moans it's rally Ritchie rally yeah
hi hi how's it going
yeah good how are you yeah I'm good I'm
good I feel like I'm cheating on my
girlfriend right now emotionally it's
quite close in it very close yeah yeah
you look like who's Cyclops right now
you smell great Bradley if I'm gonna be
in your personal space we should have
some of this when was the last time you
were this close to someone I'm this
close to my girlfriend quite a lot yeah
but you know also probably the last time
I was this close someone was with my dog
Larry I just grabbed his face that Adam
let just give him a little like a little
penguin kiss on his noise that's quite
hard to train a dog to be that close and
not lick we just do that they pull away
don't be a dog
no not Brandi or Jacob
can we work you want yeah me Pete if you
want Pete yeah you don't know like a
Pete why not
you just don't have that vibe about you
know you're too street smart if this was
the streets we'd be fighting right now I
sound like a threat well I'm not let it
does everything sounds like a threat
this close
I'm on fire you'd have nice thank you
you look nice very smart
you keep him well keep it very well
thank you
I like the volume love to the family
thank you I mean like we've already met
today but like I like you man you seem
like you're but I don't know what I feel
like I feel like we're fight yeah I
don't feel that we're fighting but in
every
we do like little yeah echoing kisses
you should have a song called penguin
kiss
how would he go we ride together you
stop we could penguin keys I wanna do
little tiny penguin kisses on your side
clubs face I'm so close to your face how
did you react to being cast in one of
the world's most popular shows what cool
yeah I was trying to keep my voice down
because I was on the bus I find it quite
funny that I got that call yeah for that
show on a bus what bus we were it was
the three to eight we on the top deck or
the bottom on the top deck yeah yeah I
was really excited by it to wait till I
got home - didn't any of it out yeah
what happened then I can't remember
anything right now but my friend who
he's also in that show room I lived with
her at the time
oh wow so did she put a word in for you
hey my flatmates around into a really
good like facial expression way he's
like looking over there the whole time
you do one to the camera I'm gonna
become a tribute version of you gonna go
around the country doing a facial
expression at Club openings we couldn't
afford rally Red Sea but we've got Tom
Ward your lady in the show your
character is always looking quite pained
and looking over there sure yeah in the
style of your character could you read
out the football scores from last
weekend please yeah about our practice
I'm sorry
Maidenhead United what Boreham wood town
working with town right there getting
there
what is called wormwood three easily one
either shut down to Dagon Dagenham and
Redbridge one Wrexham so as a musician
you're on tour a lot and spend time in
hotels hmm do you find out your new
songs are about that kind of thing more
and more so you sing about having too
many pillows and little bars of soap and
that sort of thing I've been writing
quite a lot of songs from my second
album about those hair dryers you get
because they're just not real hair
dryers it's like it's that basically
this is the power of their hair dryers
start someone playing air panpipes all
over my face well relly thank you for
letting me in your personal space
my pleasure Tom I hope it's been all
right it's um it's been really difficult
yeah it's really hard to think when
you've got someone's face this gross to
your face
penguin kiss yeah and kiss yeah penguin
kiss can have a hug yeah yeah
this is gonna be really hard to let go
now but I've spent spent so much time
like thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you thank you
[Music]